one day we're going to have a family  Congrats  are in order for Sean and Catherine Lowe  on their new bundle of joy the bachelor  stars welcomed their first child on  Saturday a healthy baby boy  on Sunday the proud parent shared their  son's first photo via Instagram and it's  too cute to handle here Catherine is  seen cutely cradling the newborn in her  arms with the caption Samuel Thomas I  think I'm in love and it gets better  Sean also posted a priceless pic with  his little boy the proud dad is all  smiles while holding his son riding in  the caption quote my boy and me talk  about cuteness overload the pair got  engaged on season 17 of The Bachelor and  when one year later with Sean and  Catherine's new addition these two  lovebirds got a sweet happily ever after